so everyone loves in tendo's new 3dsxl
portable system right it's great
games are fun but like every portable it
runs out of battery eventually and
that's kind of the biggest flaw you
always have to remember to charge it so
a company like Mugen power comes along
and they release a battery pack which is
what you're seeing on the new 3dsxl
right here it's substantial and for good
reason because it essentially multiplies
the battery life of the new 3dsxl by
three and a half times the capacity of
the original new 3dsxl x' battery is
rated at 1750 milliamps with Mugen
power's battery that number bumps up to
sixty two hundred and fifty millions so
that's great you know I travel a lot and
I find it to be really handy typically I
could get about four to five hours of
gameplay on the regular new 3dsxl with
this it was easily over 15 and that
accounts for days leaving my radio on so
I can get street passes while I was on
the move this thing cost the ninety
dollars which is not cheap therefore
this isn't going to be a product for
everybody
and it's not just the price either it
definitely hinders the portability of
the system it's significantly thicker
and significantly heavier as well but if
you're on the go and you need
entertainment you're probably not gonna
worry about that too much because you'll
be happy and thankful to at least be
able to play your system and not looking
for an outlet in the airport version
Mugen power sells this battery in three
different colors red blue and black and
the colors are very similar to the three
es XL system I have a little protective
plastic on it right here but they match
up pretty closely there are some
interesting protrusions and spaces that
are aesthetically odd but they allow you
to still access the stylus and the
cartridge slot very easily and because
you have to remove the back of the new
3dsxl to access the or change the
battery in this case Mugen power was
kind enough to include a screwdriver
with their battery so for $90 and the
added bulk that the battery brings to
the system this isn't going to be for
everybody
but if like me you travel a lot and you
like street passing and playing new
3dsxl games I can't recommend Mugen
powers 3dsxl battery enough